اضطرت إحدى مشجعات باك ستريت بويز في أتلانتا إلى
تفويت حفلتها الموسيقية بسبب تشخيص إصابتها بالسرطان ،
لكن ممرضاتها وجدوا طريقة
لتقديم أداء مفاجئ ورسم
ابتسامة على وجهها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذا فإن أماندا و  الممرضات
تغني لها كما ترى ، ودان التي
أحببت تصميم الرقصات قالت إنها كانت
تتطلع إلى الحفلة الموسيقية منذ
عيد الميلاد ، لذلك عندما بدأت الممرضات في
غناء بعض
الأغاني التي ضربت باك ستريت بويز ، بدا الأمر رائعًا ، نعم
فعلوا تغريدة شقيقة أماندا على نيك كارتر
الفيديو ولاحظ أنك تعرف أن نيك
كار معجب بالعرض أيضًا ، فقد قال
ابق على اتصال حتى نتمكن من التأكد من
أن أماندا يمكنها حضور عرض عندما تشعر
بتحسن سنكون سيارة خضراء
لطيفة جدًا منك